[Music]
it's hard to decide which we love more
Pokemon or Disney characters this artist
asks why not both you won't believe
which we character gets a maleficent
makeover stick around until the end to
find out if this is your first time here
hit that subscribe button and never miss
out don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
stitch lilo and stitch is pretty much
life we love that little girl and her
alien dog like their family stitch is
already pretty amazing on his own but
his final form will blow your mind
Stach is the first form in this amazing
evolution the artist labelled him as a
dark-type pokémon
don't let that adorable round face fool
you he's an angry little monster who's
ready to snap he seems like the least
dangerous form but we're still not
messing with him statue evolves into a
familiar stitch he can change how many
arms he has eat almost anything and
still hearts we love this little guy
even if he is chaotic what we can't get
over is the third evolution stitch he's
one bad hombre he could snap a car in
half with his bare hands he's not just
all brawn either he's incredibly smart
and has designed his own laser cannon
his homemade weapon can take out
satellites from space stitch was always
clever but such is a formidable genius
his hulking size combined with his
intelligence make him unstoppable we
can't help but wonder what his attacks
are Mickey Mickey Mouse is an iconic
character he's the face of Disney his
face is one of the most recognizable
symbols of the company we love that
little mouse and seeing his evolution is
so cool the first form is called Mimi
he's a normal type Pokemon described as
shy and small he likes to hang out by
himself
the second stage is the Mickey we know
and love he loses the shyness of his
first form and becomes the friendly guy
we love Mickey is kind of a leader
imagining him as a shy loner is a
stretch and that's not even the most
strange form he'll take our famous
Mickey's third form is where things get
really interesting his final form is
called Mick
Folie he is a fighting type and we're
shook
can you imagine friendly Micky being
aggressive Nick Foley is always ready
for a fight
ripped Mickey is definitely a huge
change we have a lot of questions what
does this new Mickey's voice sound like
what inspired the artist to make such a
huge leap where did the inspiration for
a Mickey and Gaston mashup come from
rise spirit obviously has no problem
thinking outside the box
Sulli Monsters Inc is the perfect film
to pull Pokemon inspo from what better
to turn into Pocket Monsters than actual
monsters
we love Sulley he's a good guy and his
fur is so cute as a pokemon his first
form is almost too cute to handle he
looks like a fuzzy gumdrop the first
evolution subby is mischievous and
friendly and gets a major kick out of
scaring people
the second form is the Sully were used
to he's good-natured and hard-working
he's a dark fighting type who's an
expert at scaring people the real
shocker is his final form he's not the
big furry kitty were used to he's
sporting a spiked buckler on his
shoulder giving him a warrior vibe his
nose ring only exaggerated s' the tough
look his ponytail makes him look every
bit the orcish spider he has given up on
the scare industry he's become more of a
recluse and withdrawn from society that
makes him even scarier what could have
possibly made sweet Sulley into such a
scary grump we're not even sure we want
to know what could cause this kind of
personality change we're used to
happy-go-lucky Sully who loves kids and
his friends this tough version is a
complete reimagining Walley
everyone loves robots and wall-e might
be the most beloved robot of all time
he's sweet thoughtful hardworking and
brave Wally can teach us all a thing or
two about self care the first evolution
of this adorable machine is wall Beebe
he's a lot like the form we all know
he's super clean and Mike's to take care
of himself he's even more adorable than
we imagined he's a steel ground-type
pokémon with a heart of gold
second form is Wally he's a more
advanced evolution with higher AI he can
handle much more complicated tasks with
two such adorable forms down we bet
you're ready to see the third wall Z is
is different from the first two forms as
possible
forget the tiny adorable robot we all
know and love wall Z is a 23 foot tall
behemoth he can easily lift over 300
pounds like it's nothing he's as tall as
a three-story house the artist referred
to this as his ultimate form and we
can't disagree
he's a seriously beefy but he looks like
a transformer we want to know if he has
the same personality in the huge body
who everyone knows Winnie the Pooh his
chubby yellow bear is close to our
hearts around the world artists rise
spirit captures his sweet personality
perfectly in his first form many the
Pooh is as sweet as his beloved honey
he's a cute little cub who loves a good
snack he can help but all fall in love
with this cuddly old bear this form
makes total sense and fits right in with
the character we know in the next
transformation Winnie the Pooh is a
friendly guy who loves honey more than
anything else he spends his time playing
with his friends and plotting to get
snacks he might be a little absent
minded but he's still lovable he's kind
compassionate and loyal the third form
turns the character on its head
can you wrap your head around skinny the
Pooh this normal type Pokemon decided to
change its life quite a bit he gruesome
sassy bangs and decided to get fit
skinny thought about his health and
decided against an entirely sugar based
diet it's so hard to think of Pooh as a
health nut that golden pot belly is as
famous as the 100 Acre Wood can you
imagine who sharing a carrot salad with
rabbits Mike Wazowski if you had to pick
the most popular one-eyed monster on
earth we're guessing you'd pick Mike
Wazowski he's charming funny and good
with the ladies he's the perfect Powell
for Sully this reimagining of his
character starts by playing off of his
cuteness he's big round and adorable I
am cute is the first form of this
Pokemon he knows exactly how cute he is
imagine getting puppy-dog eyes from the
sky the second form is Mike he's a
friendly guy with a big best friend he
likes to make eye puns and spend time
with his Snoopy this dark-type is a
swell guy
it's his third form that will shock you
can you imagine Mike Wazowski as a scary
monster rice spirit can I am scary is
the third form in this evolution he's
one of the most powerful monsters and
can consume 3,000 pounds of food a day
we're not sure if we want to know what
he's always ready to eat at worst his
food source could be something really
gruesome at best he's gunning down
thousands of pounds of gross monster
food every day yuck
can you imagine the burps Oh wouldn't it
be easier if it all just blew away
piglets one of the most beloved
characters in the Hundred Acre Wood is
piglet he's little timid and so cute
he's afraid of everything came in his
own shadow how can you resist the sweet
little bacon bits rice spirits must
really love this little guy he gives
this character the Pokemon treatment
while preserving his personality
perfectly the first evolution is babe
he's a normal type Pokemon who's even
cuter than the inspiration he's
teeny-tiny and ultra shy he's usually
hiding and isn't spotted very often we
wonder if this makes him a rare Pokemon
to catch tiny little babe evolves into
our piglets the little guy isn't very
much bigger he's still just as nervous
and shy as babe and often hides when
someone is nearby
once he trusts you he's a loyal friend
like his buddy Pooh his final form is
hilarious Boris is the funniest possible
version of piglets even if this giant
version is less anxious there aren't
many places he can hide we want stats on
just how big this pig is we want to hear
his voice thinking of piglet as a fully
grown boar is too fun how did our little
piggy get so big Eve Disney has a knack
for creating lovable robots little Eve
is a great pal for wall-e reimagined as
a Pokemon she's even cuter Wray spirit
begins this evolution with a cute little
steel flying type named eveyone Eevee
one looks like a fancy alarm clock with
wings she loves to learn and improve
herself constantly you have to admire
that kind of dedication to personal
growth she's absolutely adorable her
second form Yves is familiar to Disney
fans everywhere she's dedicated to any
task she's given she'd even sacrifice
herself to get the job done
her final form is named Evangelion she's
the perfect probe droid her equipment is
really advanced she has super high-tech
scanners and incredible flight speed
she's also armed with an extremely
powerful plasma cannon it can destroy
anything that gets in her path we don't
envy anyone who gets in her way
it's hard to imagine the sweet little
Eve with such a powerful weapon what
could she possibly need it for what
pokémon attacks does she have other than
just her cannon Eve appears to be more
armored than her previous version - is
someone shooting back at her what has
Evangelion got herself mixed up in goofy
when it comes to famous Disney dogs
goofy is the original he's been beside
Nicky from the very beginning we love
this silly oaf the first evolution rice
beard imagines is goo goof is a
normal-type pokémon he's a sweet and
friendly little puppy he loves nature
and probably belly rubs - how adorable
is that the goof evolves into a familiar
face goofy goofy is really laid-back
he loves to laugh and have a good time
he's a real class clown and is known to
get everyone else in on the fun - his
sense of humor is really important to
him in his final form things take a turn
he becomes a dark-type with a penchant
for racketeering goo father is the boss
he runs things it's hard to imagine
goofy as a good fella but rice spirit
went there
he's a vaguely threatening figure who
isn't to be disobeyed anyone who doesn't
do what the boss says will get an offer
they can't refuse we're not entirely
sure what that means but it doesn't
sound good we're definitely not going to
test it seeing this silly dog as a slick
Don is an impressive leap of creativity
Minnie the only Disney face more iconic
than Mickey's is Minnie's she's the
feminine mascot of the entire brand we
love Minnie's cute style and bubbly
personality
she loves Mickey and all of their
friends as a Pokemon
she doesn't disappoint each evolution is
adorable the character she's mashed up
with in her final form will blow your
mind the first form is named Minnie that
spelled PIM I in I Minnie is a tiny
little round Mouse she's just as upbeat
as the Minnie we all know and love
Minnie fairy-type who loves music she
can often be found humming her favorite
tunes she may be small but her
personality is larger than life
Minnie evolves into the mouse we've
known for years she's playful cute and
even a little flirty in her final form
she evolves into minutes that's right
our sweet Minnie spelled mi in an ie is
mashed up with the wicked sorcerer
Maleficent Minnie's heart of gold
transforms this character completely
she's a charming sorcerer who is
compassionate and a total cutie can you
imagine the big-eared dragon this little
sweetheart turns into what kind of
spells can a mini Maleficent casts we
can't help but love this mashup rise
spirit really nails both characters with
his art we hope you'd like to see these
characters evolve before your eyes we'll
catch you next time
[Music]